activists in Portland think the best way
to end the city's rampant homeless
crisis to get this give out more tents
but drug counselors say the plan is not
helping the situation
this is an empty tent erected by
activists to encourage
back in the day when we did Outreach our
Focus was what's the permanent solution
how are we going to help them today get
them off the streets solve the problem
you know move on to the next person and
then eventually just became here's
another tent here's another tarp here's
another peanut butter sandwich if money
were the solution we would have already
solved it
can be two fronts this is this is
Hometown this is home territory for you
what are your reactions as someone that
loves that City knows that City believes
in that City then what is your answer to
this this some of the answers or
reactions to how we deal with the
homeless it's heartbreaking we're
talking about immigration earlier this
is completely inhumane they see human
beings as being disposable Social
Services have totally broken down in
this city uh they have an ultra liberal
mayor Ted wheeler who fights with the
activists who are just trying to
cannibalize each other and this is their
vision of Utopia it's awful they don't
do it right their Outreach is bad they
don't get people into rehab they rarely
get people into shelters about three
percent of the unhoused population are
actually in housing or shelters or jail
or a nursing facility and you know the
older population the homeless population
is growing in Portland just like it is
in Southern California they don't have
any real solutions they just like to
yell about things and they're buying
people tents and they are making a it's
so much worse it just it shows that they
don't care and money we've seen this all
over the country money does not solve
homelessness systems do and they refuse
to get operating systems and shame on
them Dana you have an opinion on this
well it was interesting because you have
experience in Portland and Los Angeles
and New York so you've seen this and
when she said
that wasn't my point but I think just to
reiterate what you're saying is that
money is not solving the problem and the
other thing is it's going to get worse
especially in Portland why because
they're driving the businesses out last
week on this show you saw a story about
Walmart deciding to close two of its
stores right there in Portland that's a
lot of jobs that's where a lot of people
got their services I mean because that's
also the pharmacy
and that's also where you get your
pictures printed if you're going to do
something like that but you get your
groceries there and everything that you
need and now they're leaving as well
that means that other businesses are
going to leave so it's a downward spiral
Jesse what you think about this
creatively what what more can they be
doing I mean I think I I we struggle
with this in New York what can we be
doing to deal with this issue more
effective well I wouldn't make Rock
Bottom more comfortable that's what I
would start with and the more money you
send the more homelessness increases so
someone's skimming the money off the top
at these organizations because you
shouldn't want to continue homelessness
just so you can stay in business and
that's what it looks like I know a guy
out in Long Island that works with a lot
of homeless people and this has nothing
to do with money he takes them to his
Park and he has them pick up garbage and
what that does is it kind of gives them
a sense of accomplishment and then other
people in the community go I walk
through this park all the time this park
looks and spend thank you guys very
much for your contribution to this park
and these guys hear this and they you
know gives them a sense of dignity gives
them a sense of accomplishment and
self-worth and you money can't buy that
you have to get that yourself with
things like that like action and doing
and right now they're just languishing I
take the money every pick up the garbage
but that's me right now one nation what
would you say to this as you think about
ways in which we can be creative I don't
mean we should give people things
we have to talk about oh we have to talk
to the people who are homeless and we
you know the image was originally when
homelessness really started taking root
or when you're younger it's man they
can't make their rent payment they're
out on their own these families are
stuck it turns out there's mental mental
illness a lot of former soldiers a lot
of them are in the military a lot of
them are drug addicted all related to
the blood of it related to The Border
too and sometimes people have to be what
mayor Adams said at least gave lip
service to mandated scooped up by Guru
Giuliani did put in facilities and try
to rehab them and get them back I tell
you um I have a relative that's living
in New Orleans they're having the time
of their lives living under the bridge
in this homeless Community blasting
music having birthday parties some have
just checked out of society don't want
to pay rent anymore so there are
subcultures within subcultures I think
it's military who has trouble adjusting
back which is sinful that we did and I
think number two I think the drugs and
meant overall mental illness and it's
just destroyed Portland when Phil Knight
comes out and says uh I'm a Nike guy I I
have to save this city vote Republican
and they don't and things get worse what
are people going to have to do to change
policy so unless we're having a birthday
party yeah he lives under a bridge what
did you say oh if you go into the bridge
in New Orleans underneath the the main
thoroughfare they're having parties
they're living lives
I misunderstood you I thought you said
your family was living under the bridge
I have a relative who lives have to
drive through there every day okay now
it sounds like sounds like you should
take better care of your mother I wonder
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now